♪ ♪
>> Greg: AFTER MUCH OUTCRY,
TWITTER HAS REINSTATED THE
ACCOUNT OF CONSERVATIVE IRAQ WAR
VETERAN JESSE KELLY AFTER HE WAS
PERMANENTLY BANNED, PERMANENTLY
FOR VIOLATING THE PLATFORMS
POLICIES.
WHICH POLICIES?
NOT SURE, SINCE TWITTER REALLY
HASN'T SAID.
WE DO KNOW IT WASN'T FOR BEING
ANTI-SEMITIC BECAUSE LOUIS
FARRAKHAN IS STILL WELCOME.
TWITTER IS A COMPANY.
IT CAN TOSS ANYONE IT WANTS.
IF I OWN A BAR AND YOU ARE BEING
A JERK, YOU ARE GONE.
THE QUESTION IS WHETHER WHO
STAYS AND WHO GOES.
IF THIS GUY WAS PICKED UP FOR
BEING A JERK, THEN LET'S KICK
OFF ALL THE JERKS, RIGHT?
THEN THERE GOES TWITTER.
IF THE GUY ACTUALLY HARASSED
SOMEONE, TWITTER SHOULD HAVE
SAID SO.
IT MAKES YOU WONDER IF TWITTER'S
TREATMENT IS FAIR.
AND WHEN THEY HAVE CHANGED THEIR
MINDS IF JESSE HADN'T BEEN ON
TUCKER CARLSON LAST NIGHT?
>> THEY HAVE GIVEN ME NO
EXPLANATION AS THEY TOLD
CONGRESS THEY WOULD GIVE
EXPLANATIONS.
ALL THEY SENT WAS AN EMAIL THAT
SAID YOU ARE PERMANENTLY BANNED.
YOU CAN'T APPEAL IT FOR REPEAT
OF THE RULES VIOLATIONS.
I DON'T VIOLATE THEIR RULES.
I DON'T CUSS.
I DON'T HARASS PEOPLE.
I DON'T DO THOSE UGLY THINGS
SOME PEOPLE DO.
TWITTER IS GOING TO BECOME WHAT
THEY ARE.
MY ACCOUNT VANISH LIKE A
HILLARY CLINTON EMAIL.
>> Greg: TUCKER CARLSON DID
NOT BLINK ONCE.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT MR. KELLY SAID
TO GET HIM IN HOT WATER BUT THE
TREND IS LARGER THAN ANY ONE
DUDE.
IT'S PART OF A LARGER THINK
CULTURE WHERE GROUPTHINK
MONITORS AN ACTIVIST MAINSTREAM
MEDIA WEBSITES AND SOCIAL
JUSTICE MOBSTERS TARGET
DISSENTERS IN THIS ATTACK
TYPICALLY GOES IN ONE DIRECTION.
LEFT TO RIGHT.
THE RIGHT RARELY TITLES SO
TWITTER THINK THEY DON'T MATTER.
MAKE A BAD JOKE, USE THE WRONG
PRONOUN, GOD HELP YOU.
YOU WILL GET DOXXED, ANNOYED AT
HOME, FIRED FROM GOOGLE, KICKED
OFF TWITTER.
WHAT'S THE SOLUTION?
TO PARAPHRASE WALTER KERN, AS
TWITTER LIMITS EXPRESSION, IT
STARTED TO FEEL LIKE TACIT
APPROVAL TO SAY SO MAYBE IT'S
TIME TO MOVE ON ITS ARTS AND
FREEDOM OF OUR OWN.
I AM AMBIVALENT ABOUT THIS
BECAUSE WHEN I SAY GET OFF
TWITTER, IT'S BECAUSE WE ALL
HAVE "THE FIVE."
WE HAVE A PLACE WE CAN EXPRESS
OUR OPINIONS.
I SAY HATE TWITTER.
GET OFF TWITTER.
BUT IF SOMEONE LIKE JESSE KELLY
IS KICKED OFF TWITTER COME HE
DOESN'T HAVE A PLACE TO GO AND
SHOUT LIKE I DO OR YOU DO.
>> Dana: YOU MAKE A GOOD POINT
ABOUT TWITTER.
IT'S A PRIVATE COMPANY.
THEY CAN MAKE THESE DECISIONS
BUT TUCKER BROUGHT UP LAST NIGHT
THAT THESE PRIVATE COMPANIES ARE
ACTING LIKE MEDIA COMPANIES.
MEDIA COMPANIES ARE ACTUALLY
REGULATED DIFFERENTLY AND
THERE'S A LOT OF HEAT ON ALL OF
SILICON VALLEY.
THE REGULATORY PUSHES COMING
FROM THE RIGHT AND LEFT BUT FOR
DIFFERENT REASONS.
I DON'T THINK IT WILL ACTUALLY
END UP GETTING TO ANY SOLUTION.
AT THIS POINT, I THINK YOU'RE
RIGHT.
THERE IS NO OTHER PLACE TO GO
FOR PEOPLE -- I GUESS THERE IS.
YOU CAN GO TO FACEBOOK.
THEN YOU HAVE THOSE PROBLEMS.
>> Greg: EVERY PLACE HAS A
PROBLEM.
EXCEPT HERE, JESSE.
>> Jesse: NOT WATTERS' WORLD.
>> Greg: DO YOU THINK TWITTER
IS RESPONDING OUT OF FEAR FROM
FOCUS PRESSURE.
IF THREE PEOPLE WILL GET ON
TWITTER AND THEY BOMBARDED THEM.
THAT'S HOW I FEEL.
>> Jesse: I THINK LIBERALS
MIGHT COMPLAIN MORE AND TARGET
CONSERVATIVE SPEECH MORE
ACTIVELY.
I DON'T THINK CONSERVATIVES
REALLY CARE THAT MUCH WHEN
LIBERALS GO OFF BECAUSE THEY GO
OFF SO OFTEN.
EXCEPT SOMEONE HIGH-PROFILE LIKE
LOUISVILLE OR CONGO I THINK
THAT'S A HUGE DOUBLE STANDARD.
JACK DORSEY, THE CEO, ADMITTED
THERE IS A HUGE INSTITUTIONAL
PROBLEM AT TWITTER.
HE SITS CONSERVATIVE EMPLOYEES
"DON'T FEEL SAFE TO EXPRESS
THEIR OPINIONS" AT THE COMPANY
AND IT'S A BIG PROBLEM.
OVER 90% OF DONATIONS IN THE
2016 PRESIDENTIAL CYCLE FROM
TWITTER AND OTHER SOCIAL MEDIA
COMPANIES WENT TO
HILLARY CLINTON.
REMEMBER WHEN TWITTER ACTUALLY
DEACTIVATED DONALD TRUMP'S
ACCOUNT.
SOME RANDOM DUDE IN THE BACK OF
THE COMPANY DEACTIVATED THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
ACCOUNT.
LOOK AT THESE PEOPLE,
CONSERVATIVES WHO BEEN
DEACTIVATED OR SUSPENDED.
JAMES WOODS, LAURA BLOOMER, ALEX
JONES, CANDACE OWENS, ROGER
STONE.
I'M NOT DEFENDING ANYTHING THESE
GUYS DID BUT I CAN'T FIND ONE
PROMINENT LIBERAL THAT TWITTER
HAS --
>> Greg: I KNOW.
THERE'S A FEMINIST WHO JUST GOT
THROWN OFF BY SAYING --
I WOULD HASTEN TO SAY ALEX JONES
ISN'T A CONSERVATIVE.
HE'S A CONSPIRATORIAL.
>> Juan: A LOT OF THOSE PEOPLE
ARE CONSPIRACY THEORISTS AND
WHAT WE ARE EXPERIENCING IN THIS
COUNTRY IS A TREMENDOUS SPIKE IN
HATE CRIMES.
>> Greg: FAKE HATE CRIMES.
>> Juan: MOST OF IT IS COMING
FROM THE RIGHT.
>> Greg: FAKE HATE CRIMES ARE
COMING FROM THE LEFT.
>> Juan: TO DANA'S POINT, YOU
HAVE TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO MANAGE
IT BECAUSE THERE'S ONE LEVEL AT
WHICH YOU SAY IT'S AN OPEN
PLATFORM.
EVERYONE HAS THE RIGHT TO SAY
ANYTHING THEY WANT TO SAY BUT
WHEN IT'S USED TO PERPETUATE
HATE, BULLYING, MISOGYNY,
ANTI-SEMITISM, AS YOU POINT OUT
BY LOUIS FARRAKHAN.
I THINK THEY DO HAVE SOME
RESPONSIBILITY.
TO SAY IT'S WRONG.
>> Morgan: JACK DORSEY SHOULD
BE ASKED ABOUT LOUIS FARRAKHAN
EVERY SINGLE TIME ANYONE
INTERVIEWS HIM.
IT'S THE MOST EGREGIOUS.
SOMETHING ELSE TWITTER HAS DONE
IS IT'S TAKEN THE VEIL OFF THE
OBJECTIVITY OF REPORTERS.
WHEN I LOGGED ON LAST-MINUTE,
POLITICAL REPORTERS TAKING THE
TIME TO MAKE FUN OF MELANIA
TRUMP, THE FIRST LADY'S
WHITE HOUSE CHRISTMAS
DECORATIONS.
I GO ON TWITTER JUST TRY TO SEE
WHAT'S BREAKING, WHAT STORIES
HAVE BEEN WRITTEN AND WHAT MY
FRIENDS HAVE WRITTEN.
IT'S ONE MICROCOSM OF AN
EXAMPLE.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING AS A
POLITICAL REPORTER MAKING SNARKY
COMMENTS ABOUT WHITE HOUSE
CHRISTMAS DECORATIONS.
NO VALUE TO SOCIETY.
>> Greg: ISN'T IT GOOD FOR US
TO SEE IT?
I THINK IT'S A POSITIVE THING.
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS TRUE BUT I
WOULD LIKE TO KNOW WHAT THOSE
GUYS ARE THINKING TO SEE WHAT'S
BEHIND THEM.
THEY AREN'T TELLING YOU WHAT
THEY REALLY THINK.
>> Morgan: TWITTER IS THE ONE
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORM WHERE I GO
ON AND I GET REALLY ANGRY.
WHEN I GO ON INSTAGRAM, IC
DANA'S DOG AND OTHER FRIENDS
DOGS.
KIDS.
TWITTER HAS A VALUE.
THERE'S NO RULES OF ENGAGEMENT
ESPECIALLY FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE UNBIASED.
>> Juan: YOU DIDN'T KNOW
REPORTERS ARE SNARKY?
I CAN TELL YOU.
I HAVE A SNARKY JERK.
PEOPLE WHO SIT AROUND AND COVER
POWERFUL FIGURES.
>> Morgan: I AM SNARKY TOO.
I DON'T MIND SNARKY.
>> Juan: THAT'S THE REALITY.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT SOMETHING LIKE,
PEOPLE TALKING ABOUT HOW PEOPLE
DRESS, WHO WAS AT THE PARTY.
THIS IS WHAT HUMAN BEINGS DO.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW THE ONE
THING WE DON'T TALK ABOUT IS HOW
TWITTER OPERATES UNDER THE
ILLUSION OF BEING FREE.
WHEN IN FACT WE ARE THE PRODUCT,
RIGHT?
THEY ARE ADVERTISING.
IT'S BASED ON OUR GROUP, OR
FOLLOWERS.
IT COSTS US NOTHING TO BE ON
TWITTER AND WE THINK IT'S FREE
BUT ACTUALLY WE ARE THERE